Lee Canyon picked up 18 inches of snow
on Saturday winter storm warnings are
still in effect this morning and those
will continue until tomorrow evening so
at one point the snow was blowing
sideways that was a couple of hours ago
fortunately it looks like it's calming
down a little bit but we are expecting
lots of wind through the mountains and
even lower elevations today so if you
are headed up to Lee Canyon just dress
appropriately highs today only in the
low 30s so it's going to be cold up
there now it doesn't look like we've got
much wind out on the west side but we do
have very low clouds fog in the rural
areas and up through the mountains today
saying this morning so please be careful
I mean the air is saturated a lot of
moisture out there rain moving into
Southern California and snow as well as
Southern Arizona so you can see the
desert radar showing a lot of rain snow
over the higher elevations wow and you
can see it even up around Flagstaff if
you happen to be traveling anywhere
today in and around the Des desert areas
you're going to run into wet roads maybe
even snowy roads so we've had waves of
rain overnight and you can see the white
up here in the mountains now it looks
like we're getting some snow around
Mount potency so definitely we've had
quite a bit of snow in our spring
mountains I stopped the radar so you can
see more rain kind of gathering in the
mountains in the Foothills could be
sliding up I-15 if it holds together and
we are expecting just a slight chance of
some showers off and on through the
morning hours 48 Kyle Canyon that's it
low 30s for Lee Canyon and again winter
driving conditions four wheel tires
four-wheel drive snow tires change
chains have all of that with you if
you're headed into the mountains those
winter storm warnings in effect until
tomorrow afternoon and we are looking at
wind advisories for most areas of Clark
County and Southern Nye County that
starts at 10 and goes until 6 p.m we
could see winds over 40 miles an hour
today so please be careful out there 59
for the high maybe and we're looking for
a slight chance of thunderstorms as the
air is very destabilized and get some
breaks of sunshine now tomorrow partly
cloudy look how much cooler for the rest
of the week down to 50 for a high
morning's near freezing and we might see
some more showers on Thursday we're not
going to rule that out as that last
system moves through the West later this
week